At Google Cloud,
we give you a variety of ways to learn.
We understand that some learn best
from hands-on labs
or through self-paced video courses on sites like
Coursera and Pluralsight,
while some prefer to learn directly from
Google Authorized Instructors,
or even a combination of all three methods.
When it comes to instructor-led training,
it’s not always easy to get a group of
people physically together;
but did you know you can get all the benefits
of in-person classroom training
without the hassle of travel?
We call this a virtual instructor-led training.
With Google Cloud virtual instructor-led training,
our certified instructors use the same curriculum
as our in-person training.
They will take you through the same demonstrations,
and run the same hands-on activities as they
would if you were in the same room together.
The instructor and students connect via webcam,
developing a sense of community
like a traditional classroom.
This creates an engaging environment
to answer questions
and aid in supporting students individually.
To make things fun,
we use interactive tools like
quizzes, polls, and even games!
In the virtual classroom,
flexibility is paramount.
Students can join from different locations
across multiple time zones.
Our customers rave about our
virtual instructor-led training.
With one organization,
we ran 17 unique virtual classes
for 409 employees
across four different time zones!
They gave the overall experience a
98% satisfaction rating.
Virtual instructor-led training offered the same
in-person experience with a certified trainer,
but at a scale and schedule logistically
difficult to achieve otherwise.
Google Cloud virtual instructor-led trainings
are open and ready for enrollment.
You can check out our classroom schedule on
https://cloud.google.com/training/courses
or reach out to your Google representative
for more information.
We eagerly await the opportunity
to e-meet you face to face in our virtual classroom.
Hope to see you there!